jalen hurts the oklahoma and alabama
quarterback second round selection by
the philadelphia eagles got a lot of
eagles fans
riled up and it has required the eagles
to spend some extra time explaining why
they did it no they're not looking to
supplant carson wentz like the packers
may be doing with jordan love and aaron
rodgers but howie roseman told nbc
sports philadelphia on monday that it
came down to regret from days gone by
drafts gone by franchise quarterbacks
gone by that he missed on in 2012 we had
a vision howie said we had a vision that
we would draft a quarterback who's been
extremely successful and i don't want
tampering charges on me but i think we
can understand who that was and then
come bless you and then come back in the
fourth round and draft a quarterback who
won a world championship for us and go
back to back and i feel like we got a
little cute i don't know that there's a
big difference between taking the 53
third pick and the 53rd pick in the
draft and taking a pick in the third
round if you feel strongly about a guy
he's talking about russell wilson bottom
line and he's got regrets for not taking
russell wilson they took nick foles
after russell wilson that year so uh he
didn't want to miss on russell wilson
well here's the thing chris
if he thinks jalen hurts is like a
russell wilson what is the thank you
jalen hurts
that's confusing right i don't
understand that you know yes they
they've kind of made these statements
that it's not about carson wentz and
it's a weapon for the offense but when
you make that statement you're saying
that you think this guy could be russell
wilson-ish so that would lead me to
believe that in two years we're gonna
have a quarterback competition in
philadelphia
you know which which there's just no way
again
i like jalen hurts the prospect there's
potential here he is a below average nfl
thrower i mean below average there's no
question about he doesn't even want to
throw he wants to run first that was the
number one thing that jumped off to me
in the pocket there's people wide open
all over the field against in oklahoma
games he just he wants to check his eyes
down and go so yeah that's a little
confusing but i don't think jalen hurts
is going to threaten carson wentz
anytime soon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports